[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends uh
and welcome to another episode of uh
experiments uh today's um experiment
that we wanted to do was basically go
out there and find out if does people
know about Ramadan uh when we put them
in a certain situation about fasting and
we need water or dat to break off us are
they really going to help us or they
just going to say look mate you're a
terrorist or no sorry I don't want to
help you let's go and find out and in
see what happens have you got 2 minutes
I'm stuck in a bit of a dilemma uh
basically uh I'm fasting uh today I
don't know if you know if Ramadan yeah
basically what it is is I left my money
and my cars in the car and basically I
just need to break my f with water or
dates so I just wondering is there any
chance you can just get me water sorry
I'm not a bigger like no no actually
this is no I'm no excuse I lost my car
today are you serious yeah so I'm out of
cash
same I'm sorry I can't get you excuse me
sorry sorry to it's going to sound a bit
crazy but basically I'm fasting I don't
know if you know it's Ramadan and
basically I my money and my uh cards i't
got anything on me I just need water I
don't need money I I have I've got this
but it's got crap in sorry I really
appreciate no
worries excuse me I'm going a to I don't
have my money on me do you have like
water all day I can break my car
you can walk break my water
water
sorry bit little little bit of a dilemma
I'm fting I'm I don't know if you can
tell interet um I've left my money uh
like in my friend's car and he's
basically just driven off and I need to
break my fast I've been fasting all day
haven't eaten or drunk nothing I don't
want money or nothing I was just
wondering if you have like water
something oh sorry mate I lit got sh gum
but that's not going to be the best
thing in the world it wouldn't be now
well basically I just wanted to let you
guys on this social experiment so the
cameras over there and we're basically
just we're recording for YouTube we're
letting people know about Muslims that
they fasting Ramadan ET and stuff like
that so sorry excuse me um minutes what
you want um I'm
fasting
water thank
you see um I'm in a bit of a dilemma at
the moment I'm fasting it's Ramadan have
you heard of Ramadan yeah yeah yeah my m
and d oh is it okay yeah I need to break
my f do you have any water time uh
yeah thank you um yeah we're just doing
like a social experiment you want to
keep it no no no I was just it was a
social experiment to see if who would
help me out and it thank you anyway oh
no
worries experiment just wanted to know
do you guys know about Ramadan yeah my
mom and dad at really yeah okay all
right do you guys know about it she told
me a bit about it yeah is it what do you
know about it I was going to say what I
was going to say is it time you PR fast
no not
yet you literally just said it's like 19
hours what you know about Ramadan no not
much I admit I don't know a lot is it
okay yeah we're just going to have
social experiment like people would help
us they say you know go where you
terrorist or something like that oh no
we just want to see said that no no no
haven't actually so it's been good but
maybe I don't know maybe London's a
biters well you you've been like the
first person to um help us out we're the
first person to help you out yeah
really I could what did people just say
no yeah like no sorry you don't have
nothing or just like no I would I would
have put you a bottle of water or get
like or salt you can have
dat thank Anye a bit of a dilemma I was
just wondering if you guys can help me
basically I I forgot my money and my
cards and basically I need to break my
far soon I'm not I don't want money do
you have water or dick I can break my f
with so you what I don't have any food
on me bro you have like water or
something okay thank you very much I
really appreciate that's cool man um do
you guys know about Ramadan yeah yeah
yeah you Muslim no I'm Christian oh
you're Christian okay all right yeah
basically uh sorry here that's okay yeah
basically was a social experiment um got
a camera there uh I just wanted to know
if you guys know
about thank you I really appreciate it
basically what we're doing is I'm a
YouTuber I do videos on YouTube um I
just wanted to know if people know about
Ramadan are they going to help they're
going to be like move away you terrorist
or something like that you get me so we
just trying to see what people do but I
really appreciate thank you very much
sometimes as well on YouTube uh it's you
want to write my YouTube name down yeah
it's Ali Ali da excuse me guys sorry to
bother you um I'm just stuck in a bit of
a dilemma uh I'm fasting I don't know if
you guys know it's Ramadan and I left
all my money in the car and I need to
break my fast in about 20 minutes with
water dat so I was wondering have you
can you just get me water I just need
water if you have I have no I don't want
money is there anywh you can get me
water water yeah yeah if it's possible
I'm sorry I'm just a bit of Dil
I'm not fun around here where is
the maybe that
place can you give me water thank you oh
by the way um there was a social
experiment the camera is there oh yeah
yeah so we just do you have you do you
know about Ramadan yeah Ramadan yeah
okay that's great what we're doing is
we're just stopping people see if they
will actually help are they aware of
Ramadan stuck in a I'm stuck in a bit of
a dilemma um I'm I'm fasting
you know fasting yeah it's Ramadan yeah
basically I forgot my cards and my money
and I need I don't want money from you
guys I need water or something to break
my fast so I was wondering do you guys
have is it okay have have you have you
heard of Ramadan before but you can L
because the day is up what you need to
wait when the day is down oh when the
day when the sun when the sun is down
okay so you do know about Ramadan yeah
are you no no basically it's a it's a
I'm I'm a YouTuber there's a camera
there uh we're doing a social experiment
to see if people know about Ramadan and
if they will give us something to drink
so thank you very much um sorry M sorry
to stop you just got two minutes
basically what what is I'm stuck in a
bit of dilemma I'm fasting I don't know
if you know Ramadan um yeah I'm fasting
and basically what is I've left my money
and everything in the car and I need to
break my fast I need water or dates if
you just if you can just get me water or
dates is that is that possible I'm sorry
I've got I've got money but it's just
I've left everything the kind I have to
break my fast with water days you need a
I just need water or just anything that
you need a c yeah
feel go CH before before before you
before it's a social experiment so um
it's for it's for YouTube sorry the
camera's there basically I'm really I'm
really sorry to stop it's just what
we're doing is we're just want to see if
people are you aware of Ramadan dad you
have you heard of Ramadan I've heard of
it yeah sure okay I really appreciate it
man thank you very much you know what it
is it's just we're just doing an
experiment to find out what people help
you they know about Ramadan do you know
I'm fasting um it's Ramadan at the
moment is there any way that you could
like give me some water or something to
talk can break my f sorry any water
water water do you know about Ramadan
yes yeah we're fast at the moment that's
all I have thank you so much you want to
keep you uh you know what no that's fine
um the reason that we do this we're
going to ask we're just doing a social
experiment we just want to see who knows
about Ramadan and about Islam and what
we're doing so yeah we actually very
fast at half n so we yeah do a social I
thought I'd ask to see you know who
would be generous and thank you very
much um I'm fasting as you know it's I
don't know if you know it's Ramadan yeah
basically what is I've left my money and
my card in my car and I need to break my
f with water or days I'm just wondering
can you get me a water or if you just
have a pound I I will give it back to
you I'm really sorry it's just I'm just
stuck and I'm not coming around it's all
right don't worry thank you very much I
really appreciate
it you better not be lying cuz I I got
an iPhone I don't need a pow
yeah by the way you can stop there it
was a social experiment really yes uh
sorry about that the camera is there
what yeah basically what we're doing we
just want uh to know if people know
about Ramadan are they going to help are
they just going to be like no so that
that's what we just doing it so brothers
and sisters as you saw for yourself uh
the experiment that took place a lot of
people know about Islam a lot of people
know about Ramadan about fasting they
know so much so that when we approached
certain certain uh people when was
asking about you know if you can just if
we can get me a water or date some of
them said oh it's not even time for you
to break the fast yet and yeah I have
heard about Ramadan and many other stuff
so what that shows us is that uh
it's a narration of the Prophet
sallallahu alhi wasallam that Islam will
enter every household so we can see from
that clearly that people actually hear
about it and they know about it so the
fact that they want uh uh the fact that
they wanted they wanted to help us is it
shows to you that you know as as you
know when we look at the media a lot of
people it's that they hate Islam and
they don't want Islam to be there but
when we're out there and we speak to
people and um we saw what kind of
reaction they gave a lot of them really
were helpful like 90% of people were
really helpful we did get a bit of odd
looks but majority of the the time
people wanted to help us gave their
water some some guy even had like a
protein shake he was like I would have G
you this so it shows that people are
kind and this this this bigotry that the
media portrays I truly believe that it's
really uh different out there than what
the media portrays so we have learned a
lesson from this that people do know
about Ramadan and it should encourage us
to give da because there's a lot of
people that know about Islam so if
you're a Muslim and you're watching this
please if you have a neighbor or a work
colleague tell them about Islam tell
them what Ramadan is about cuz you know
it's not just about abstaining from food
you know we don't we don't uh um you
know we don't have Ramadan just just to
say you know I'm going to stay away from
food and drink no it's to you know
purify yourself stay away from sins Etc
so um if you're a non-muslim I hope
you've benefited from this video if you
want to know more about Islam um please
do you can uh come and ask me on
Facebook yourself or we'll have a link
here in which you can order your free
Quran that's about it from me brothers
and sisters hope you enjoyed the video
please do share with your friends and
family
[Music]